hai visto kami te l'avevo detto era
questo che intendevo non occorrono tante
parole
i veri viaggiatori partono per partire
basta quo rilievi simili a palloncini
che sono il caso nuova eternamente
dicono sempre andiamo e non sanno perché
i loro desideri hanno la forma delle
nuvole ana attenta alla strada
seconda stella a destra
questo è il cammino sarà radio amica e
goditi il paesaggio attenzione che qui
si va a somewhere over the rainbow
perché non è solo la sigla di
donnavventura e anche lo scopo del
nostro viaggiare trovare il tesoro
nascosto in fondo all'arcobaleno in
questi anni ho avuto la fortuna e la
possibilità di vedere il mondo ma ha
incrociato sguardi di bambini curiosi ho
ricambiato sorrisi di donne velate o
stretto mani di uomini che attraverso i
segni le cicatrici che le solcano
raccontano storie di una vita vera
vissuta fino all'ultimo respiro
una vita sicuramente distante anni luce
dalla mia dietro una scrivania davanti
allo schermo di un computer con la
parola però sempre di misurarmi con
qualcosa di nuovo
ho capito di essere una cittadina
privilegiata del mondo e non sono
l'unica ho avuto accanto a me delle
donne speciali all'inizio sconosciute
poi diventate amiche e infine sorelle
delle quali è molto difficile se non
impossibile fare a meno una volta
terminata l'avventura vissuta insieme
perché loro e solo loro con me è come me
hanno vissuto un'esperienza
straordinaria una di quelle che ti
cambia e ti segna per sempre
sono partita la prima volta senza sapere
bene cosa aspettarmi ma carica di sogni
desideri e speranze
e con un bagaglio vuoto pronto ad essere
riempito solo di ricordi da quel giorno
ho percorso migliaia di chilometri e
attraversato decine di paesi ma non sono
ancora sazia ho ancora fame di
conoscenza e sete di sapere ogni volta
che torno sono sempre pronta a ripartire
mi sembra di essere arrivata alla fine
di aver raschiato il barile fino in
fondo alla ricerca delle ultime energie
rimaste e che avevo a disposizione
poi tornata alla vita di tutti i giorni
invece mi sento sempre in subbuglio e
sicuramente pronto ad affrontare un
nuovo viaggio e così mi lascio
trasportare dalle emozioni guidare dalle
passioni i piedi iniziano a scalpitare
le mani a cercare il volante gli occhi a
volgersi verso l'infinito la mente a
volare il cuore abbattere e io a sognare
mi sento diversa mi sento più ricca mi
sento nuova o qualche ruga in più i
capelli schiariti dal sole e un bagaglio
che pesa molto più di quanto avessi mai
potuto immaginare
cani cosa stai pensando
guarda che siamo quasi arrivate sei
stata brava hai visto che qui tutto
funziona alla perfezione quando ognuna
impara al proprio compito
ci si aiuta si sta stretto contatto
tutti i giorni 7 giorni su 7 24 ore al
giorno non esistono sabati non esistono
domeniche non c'è neanche uno spazio da
ritagliarsi tra se stesse ed è così che
ci si conosce e a quel punto basta anche
solo uno sguardo per sapere come
comportarsi
che cosa dire ma soprattutto dove andare
hai ragione ripartono i miei pensieri
non smetteremo mai di esplorare e alla
fine di tutto il nostro andare torneremo
al punto di partenza per conoscerlo per
la prima volta ma ditemi cosa il viaggio
per voi
cos'è
libertà ecco il viaggio e libertà e
spensieratezza
allora il nostro può essere considerato
un viaggio è un problema di orientamento
se soliti prendere il cellulare
utilizzare google maps e invece
per noi al cellulare prende il posto la
cartina geografica
oppure avete presente quelle mattine che
avete già in mente come vestirvi non
esiste uniforme uguale per tutti e
pronte a partire
donnavventura è questo cappello vero
senza questo cappello 6 perduta no torni
provi a casa non parti più perché
donnavventura un po in posizione le
tabelle di marcia sono molto toste i
tempi sono stretti e la strada è tanta
da percorrere quest'anno in questa
spedizione mi è stata affidata un'auto
billy mentre ana stava su jolly
donnavventura e anche 500 chilometri uno
stop
ore e ore al volante chilometri su
chilometri
rispettando l'unico codice valido per
noi ma nadia e real carovana
e mi ricordo il caldo mi ricordo la
stanchezza la tensione del capo
spedizione che quando ci chiamava era
tutto un subbuglio mi ricordo l'ansia
che saliva
però mi ricordo anche la voglia di
conoscere di affrontare nuove esperienze
di mettermi in gioco
perché donnavventura e coraggio
il bello di questa spedizione e che non
si tratta solo di noi stesse come
singoli individui si tratta di sei
ragazze che insieme formano un solo
cuore una sola mente è una sola anima
perché donnavventura evita bonaventura
emozione
anzi cosa ti ricordano questo caso tutti
i cani mi ricorda un'esperienza che ho
vissuto in camargue
immaginatevi
fenicotteri rosa negli acquitrini tori
neri cavalli bianchi e noi sei ragazze
per me è stata la mia prima volta a
cavallo sembrerà banale ma è stata
un'esperienza veramente unica allora
tutte in sala al nostro cavallo
si comincia a passeggiare si comincia a
trattare poi qualcuna di noi comincia a
prendersi dall'entusiasmo per si va al
galoppo mai stato a cavallo la prima
volta sopra questo animale alla fine
però il panico è diventato adrenalina
pura
e questa la linea quella sono portata
con me è stata veramente un'emozione che
mi ha rubato l'anima
essendo la più giovane non mi aspettavo
non sapevo cosa aspettarmi da questo
viaggio è però mi sono sentita un po la
portavoce la forza per tutte quelle
ragazze che come me hanno hanno voglia
di sfidare loro stesse
noi siamo delle report e viaggiamo in
versi da reporter quindi il nostro scopo
è documentare la natura incontaminata i
paesaggi gli usi costumi ma soprattutto
catturare le emozioni di tutte quelle
persone che incontriamo durante i nostri
viaggi per comunicarle al mondo
diciamo che la strada è tanta il tempi
sono stretti stretti
e mi viene in mente quel mese e mezzo in
marocco strade impervie percorsi
pietrosi deserti montagne di
attraversare chi l'avrebbe mai detto che
dopo tre mesi e mezzo
fossi riuscita a percorrere 15mila
chilometri al volante del mio pick up
per me una soddisfazione unica
e perché proprio quando non ci si
aspetta nulla che si ritrovata
affrontare tutto parlo del sahara parlo
delle dune di sabbia
del era quello mio obiettivo vedere e
vivere il deserto
parlo del calo del caldo torrido dei
panorami interminabili e della felicità
nella scoperta di qualche oasi nata in
mezzo al nulla
parlo del sole cocente di chilometri di
sabbia parlo di freddo improvviso e
cielo stellato
buio profondo
silenzio
tisana calda e naso all'insù l'immenso
un tetto
stellato punteggiato da tantissime luci
una cosa immaginata sì ma vissuta della
sicura tutto un altro sapore
guidare essere in corsa da centinaia di
cammelli
e davanti a voi il cielo azzurro che
comincia a diventare viola rosso rosa
arancione una palla infuocata
che davanti a voi comincia a calare
quattro macchine che sfrecciano verso
l'infinito
il viaggio è scoperta è condivisione è
vita e allora fate come noi team big
pensate in grande e alla grande prendete
il nostro invito
fatelo vostro lasciatevi trasportare
dalle parole di questa canzone perché
noi attraverso la nostra esperienza
abbiamo capito che anche il viaggio è
innovazione
trent'anni sarete più di tutte le cose
che non avete fatto che per quelle che
avete fatto quindi mollate le cime
all'anno allontanatevi dal porto sicuro
prendete con le vostre veli 20 esplorate
sognate scoprite earth in quelli rossi
c'era una banconota da 100 euro e si
grazie